[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um so welcome everyone um those for
those of you who don't know i'm heather
hendershot director of graduate studies
and compared to media studies at mit
um so great to uh host this talk today
with jorge carabao
who is a journalist and a 2022 harvard
neiman fellow
before that he worked for four years as
the growth editor
at radio
ambulante the most popular documentary
podcast in spanish and the only one in
that language distributed by npr
there he led online and offline
engagement initiatives to grow the
community around the podcast he holds a
master's degree in media innovation from
northeastern university he's a fulbright
scholar and a google news initiative
fellow and the title of his talk today
is how to use audio storytelling to
cultivate a community and keep it
engaged so i will pass the floor over to
jorge now
thank you thank you so much heather
andrew for inviting me i'm very happy to
be here
i will share my screen i have a
presentation so
i oh let me go back because i have to
share sound
share a sound
let's do it
okay
so
i
no need to go deeper on this this is me
this is my my baby i i i work at four
years as the growth editor at lyon
bulante and yes i was
my my mission was bringing more people
in into the podcast more listeners
growing the audience that was like a
main metric but another metric of
success was creating the environment so
people would participate people would
use
as a centerpiece for civic conversations
and
making
the most
impact out of which of our journalism so
i was constantly
using the stories which were which are
episodes of 30 minutes 45 minutes every
week
to all over latin america
a little bit of context is a podcast
it's like this american life in spanish
that's how you can make an idea of what
it is and every week every tuesday we
like
an episode
and
that episode my my goal was to make it
it was
to make it as
impactful as possible and impactful by
our standards was
making it create conversations
all around the continent so that was my
job and what i what i what i want to do
in this in this presentation is to show
you some examples of how we did that
like what what kind of engagement
exercises we did and why
just like a little bit
making you see how we cooked the dish
and then
some principles that i think can be
replicated by anyone that is interested
in using storytelling and this could be
of course documentary as we did
non-fiction but also it could be fiction
and it doesn't matter necessarily that
these are audio stories to me
but
this what i learned in raymond is that
just a good story can be used to bring
the attention of the internet of people
on the internet and make it a platform
to
connect people among each other and to
create a
common purpose to
to get to know ourselves and to get to
know others so that's that i'm going to
go step by step through those
through those principles and then we can
have a q a so let's start
with this
[Music]
my
is
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so what you saw there is a video a raw
video on edited of
zoom party when the pandemic started and
the
spirit of our community was in the
lowest level
we were like we need to do something to
remind ourselves that we are not alone
that this is not a podcast that is
talking to individuals necessarily but
that this podcast is a platform of a
community that is distributed all over a
continent
in latin america in europe in the united
states there are around 90 000 people
listening to this podcast every week
and
we can do something to to remind that
if you listen to raymond
you share some things some features with
other people who also listen to
rembulante and
we can celebrate even though this is a
tough tough moment in our life we can
celebrate that we are not alone and
let's just do a party we assume let's
see what happens
and we did that so what it was the first
party
and we did four of them and to each of
them more than a thousand people
attended and they were
as you see here they were turning their
cameras on they were showing
their pets their customs their children
they were showing you their living room
they were showing you their life and
it's still to me impressive
that
people trust it so much right we are all
aware of how
the internet is a place in which
you need privacy because you don't know
what are the intentions of those who you
are interacting with with
but in this community in rayambulate's
community even though most of these
people don't know each other at all and
they're in very different backgrounds
and countries and cultures
they share something they're listening
and
because of that they trust each other
but this is not something that happened
out of the blue this is not something
that was like a random idea this was a
conclusion this was a consequence this
was a consequence of an effort of
cultivating a community around
storytelling so
there are other examples of
these kind of interactions between
strangers that listen to ray blante this
is a picture of a listening club and we
will talk about later like strangers in
their cities getting
into a place where they listen to an
episode and then have conversations
civic conversation or this these are
this is a picture of our team in 2018
when we did a
a
live show in new york and washington dc
or
yes other examples
that we're going to i am going to
describe what how we have done it
because i think that
it's it's important that we remember
that
the internet is not only that
corporative
platform in which these big corporations
are
giving you uh
some
leverage to communicate with others but
the internet is also
a network in which you can create trust
and to do that stories i think
are one of the main main things or one
of the main
channels to connect people in a way that
they trust each other and create
together so i'm going to describe you
how we did that but i think that this
can be translated to many different
contexts not only in podcasts but in
other ways other creative ways other
creative languages
so i'm going to show you some examples
of our engagement and you will
be able to listen a little bit of these
of the stories that i've learned today
by the way disclosure when i came to to
as an iman fellow i started working at
so this is a sample of what we did in
the four years that i was there
so the first one is it's uh
an exercise that we did when we
published an episode called album
denigrates or
album
and i'm going to show you but you're
going to listen to a short clip and then
i will give you more context about the
story
of venezuela
so migration is a big
theme in latin america and
in the recent years in the last five
years venezuelan migration to other
countries in the region it's a big story
so what do you just listen is anamid an
america is a venezuelan woman who
migrated to peru and it was very hard
for her to adapt to this new country not
only because she faced
xenophobia
but also because of what she just said
like
everything changes so quickly and you're
still so attached to your home country
that
you need to be living in that unstable
situation of should i
have roots in the new country should i
root myself here or should i be prepared
to move to another place what do i do
like where do i belong
and
one of the main
characteristics of rayogulante or one of
the big groups in inside the radio
mulatto community is that of migrants
many of radioable and listeners are
people who have migrated from latin
american countries to the united states
to europe to other places
in which they find new opportunities so
we knew that many listeners of
shared
kind of a similar story
or had
had lived
and experienced similar to that point of
hamir
so we try to
do something we try to
tap into that collective knowledge and
experience inside our community and
asked them
to give an amer advice or give an emer
some words of recognition and awareness
of what she was going through so we
tweeted this like as an amir our
like this
the main character of today's episode
many of the people that listen to
rambutan know what it means to be a
migrant so share a story a short story
about your experience establishing
yourself in a new place what was the
hardest thing or the most exciting thing
and we use it this hashtag
and this thing exploded
we started getting
this kind of responses
more than 10 years ago i haven't left i
haven't lived in argentina where i was
born i left i lived in puerto rico and
then i met friendship there and disgrace
now i live in bogota where the sun
kisses me and i'm
a drowned by books that don't let me go
and here i understood that to be an
immigrant can also be a nationality
and then people started sharing pictures
we didn't ask them to share pictures
they started sharing pictures of their
first
years of being migrants or this guy who
had like 3 000 retweets which was very
unusual in our in our
engagement strategy or engagement work
he said i got four years ago here in
paris with 200 aero heroes no speaking
french not knowing anyone i started
working as a dishwasher
and a year ago i brought my dad because
my mother died
and today i'm the chef of a bar i speak
french and i live with my dad in an
apartment and he was using the hashtag
and this was very intimate stories right
of people who were
somehow
reflect who felt reflected in our story
but at the same time were proud of
what came after that
turbulent first
time
or first period as migrants
went up and then people were like
acknowledging
that a podcast like chelo she's saying
when a podcast generates that listeners
make their universe bigger and multiply
the stories and this is what was going
on and this is what i think it's super
super valuable because anime story
became
the first in a block of another stories
and what was happening here is that
listeners we're making this story bigger
we're enlarging the story we're making
it more complex and the paradigm like
the first the way we understand we
usually understand our role as
storytellers is that we produce a story
we publish the story and that's it right
people can comment the story or can
share the story but what is happening
here is that people are
making the story grow with their own
stories the episode didn't end the
episode was not a discreet piece when we
published it the episode was open
and
the continuation of the episode is this
is this
and i find
striking and
beautiful
to understand storytelling as an
open-ended process
collaborative and
participative right so
this is what was going on with this
story
uh
this person is saying juarez
and the stories in this hashtag have me
crying celebrating
laughing thinking about my people so
that's just an example of how
the character of a story
and this is a nonfiction story
is not alone because you as a listener
you are also a character of the podcast
and we'll we're going to talk more about
that meta thing later
this is another example it's called milo
garde
my favorite place
and it was about
a story it was an exercise that we did
for a ritual as i will start calling it
this was a ritual that we did
when we published this story
about a group of friends in san jose
costa rica the capital of costa rica
this is a group of college friends who
started gathering at this very tiny
a
dark karaoke bar in downtown san jose
this was a bar that
almost only them attended it was not the
most popular bar it was not in not at
all in the list of touristic places in
san jose it was like a kind of secret
corner of the city that they
colored with their identities with their
joyfulness and they got to know the
the owner of the bar
and unfortunately and this is a spoiler
of the story but unfortunately the owner
of the bar was this chinese mysterious
chinese woman decided to close the plate
and with that decision their life as a
group
like took a different direction
so
we decided to focus on
something that
it was like a an important line in the
story which was these places that become
contents or become vessels of your
identity and are not the most popular
places in your city but i think we all
we all have that we all
even though even if we live in a city or
in a rural area we all have these kind
of sanctuaries that are relevant or to
the express the expression of our of our
identity of our freedom
and we wanted to know
what were those sanctuaries for our
listeners we have listeners as i told
you
everywhere in in the world mostly in the
united states a and south america and
central america also in europe and we
wanted to know what were those
sanctuaries and not only to know that
but to see them
and not only to see them but to make
them useful so we ask people what's your
favorite city in the what's your
favorite place in the city you live not
the most touristic one but the one that
you love most and mention it using
this hashtag me lugar de siempre and
we're going to make a map of places that
you cannot miss with your
recommendations
and we did this
we got this we we've got this kind of
responses so she's sharing a place in
mexico city in the biggest university
there
or this one in sierra leone in freetown
or
this one in
montreal this is like a kind of small
cafe
we got this
we got a lot of things and then we were
like okay
let's make something with this and we
created a collaborative map and this is
a very
simple thing we
created a collaborative google map so
anyone instead of sending tweets with
pictures could just create a pin in
their city
and
share it with others and the idea of
this was to create like a touristic
guide of latin american
secret places or more
loved places by listeners so as a prayer
listener if you go to argentina you will
have some options
or some places that are relevant to
listeners in argentina if you go to peru
the same if you go to colombia if you go
to the us then you will have some
reference of what are those places are
important to other listeners
and they are
organized by categories
so there were restaurants for jazz clubs
there were these bookstores there were a
also karaoke bars
a lot of stuff
and
this is
an idea that it's very like easy to
replicate
and you could
spend a lot of time trying to develop a
map or uh like the lines of code create
this in a fancy way but we were like
let's use the things that people use
that are simple to replicate and to make
this exercise because we have found that
we cannot ask
like we need to
ask for things that are not very
time demanding if we want this to be
really participative and at the same
time
it needs to be useful the incentive for
people to participate is that this will
be useful for them and for others if
it's not like that they don't they don't
they don't engage so
engagement like good practice is just
use the platforms that people use and
google docs is something that almost
everyone uses
other way of
engaging with people and making stories
live
beyond the limits of an audio story of
an episode is like this conversation
process that we started using on social
media so this is a
this is a
question that we asked in
like five months after the pandemic
started this is september 2020
a
after the worst of the quarantine we ask
people like hey
for those of you who have little
children at home what was the
most memorable game exercise or project
that you that you did with them during
work during part time so this is where a
lot of parents that had been stuck in
their apartments or houses with children
and we wanted to
we wanted them to single out that
memorable moment the memorable thing
that they did with their with their
children because we had done an episode
about that we had done an episode in
which the characters had done that so
a lot of comments about that or this one
was a one year after the pandemic was
declared and we asked people what's the
best thing that happened to you in a
year full of bad news and at the same
time like 200 comments
so we were trying to
make
conversations that were
improbable
and that we're not just for the sake of
having comments but of
making people
think about those
not i wouldn't say positive things but
things that are not usually
in the mainstream narrative of this was
a
terrible year which was or this was i
like i only i had no ideas of what to do
with my children which is true
but at the same time there were other
stuff happening right and and we wanted
to focus on that and to
use the experience of the community to
have that conversation happen
we have we also did extra episodes with
the community and because of the
community which is something that most
newsrooms
that the newsrooms usually try to avoid
because when you open the doors of your
editorial newsroom to your audience
then they will start demanding or that's
the that's the
the
fear of editors and journalists is that
they will start
demanding you to do what they want and
interfering with your creative or
editorial independence but we were like
let's just not play that game anymore
let's just actually listen like
people are listening to us let's listen
let's listen back it's the minimum we
can do like one of the rules of the
internet is
reciprocity if this is a network it
needs to be reciprocal so
we asked people what kind of stories
they wanted to to to listen to and they
voted a
like there was a big pool of suggestions
and pitches that people sent and they
voted for the stories
that
other listeners
sent that and then we prioritize and
then we would pick the winners so
uh this is one of them like this is an
episode that we did for a story about uh
trans little in argentina the first girl
that was declared
a
trans in
in the country
uh
and we did a story like that was that
was the story the story of this girl
who didn't identify with her with the
sex that she was born when when
she was born so we did a story
of
okay this is sort of a five-year-old
girl
and it's very emotional and we get to
listen to the mother and to a country
that is
debating if should be
like legally recognized or not
but
the story ends with the girl which she's
just seven years old and we wanted to
know what was the experience of
those
listeners in raymond who identify
themselves as trans and
are not
kids anymore what's this what's their
story want to see what's what will be
the life of this girl
in 10 15 years and
to answer that question we asked
listeners
in the fire strands we did an extra
episode
or we did this one and this one was
suggested by the the
the community like we want to know
what's the story in medellin which is my
city the city where i was born what's
the story imagine with narco tours
because
there is something happening in this
city and this is like a listeners and
this idea there are people coming from
all over the world to managing
to visit the places where republic lived
or the places where he where he had
where he put bombs
and i wonder why are they doing that
what what and what's the city how is the
city dealing with that
troubled past
so because i was there as a reporter i
did the story about the spot and i did
one of these tours that took me to her
seminar to the to his thumb
that took me to the place where he was
in jail to his building like a building
that he built that where he lived and
then i was able to talk to one of the
guides of those stories to ask them why
are you doing this like why are you
glorifying this
person who
victimized so many people and it's a
it's a very i think powerful story to
touch the identity of a city and we did
it thanks to to listeners who suggested
it and to other listeners who voted for
it or we did this one in which we tell
the story of rayon
so this is a mezza story like this is
the story
of a podcast who makes stories
that make stories which is also which
became the most listening episode
we also have fun interactions in social
media and
like for example a question those who
listen to podcasts when they were in
public transportation or in their cars
during the pandemic
when are you listening to podcasts right
now and there are like 660 responses
like
this is a like podcast are a medium that
somehow demands routines like you listen
to your podcast usually when you're
doing something that you
constantly do going out for a walk
going to
commuting
washing your dishes whatever so now that
the routines are so messed up because of
the pandemic like when are you listening
to them or
another question is how would you
explain what apocalypse is to your
grandfather grandmother without
mentioning the words radio and internet
because we're all the time constantly
exploring
how do people think about this medium
how do they how do they relate with this
media which is essential if we want to
be useful and and
deliver our message we need to
understand what does this mean to them
so these kind of questions we did then
or another one to grow and to expand the
network we ask people like mention a
friend
that doesn't listen to podcasts and tell
us
about a detail about that person
her favorite movie her
saudia call sign a secret whatever you
want to tell us and then we will respond
we'll reply
with the ideal episode for them
so they started listening to our podcast
so we were using data
from
the listeners
and
at the same time we were referring we
will we will try to hook those referrals
with a personalized recommendation
but
our
strategy
engagement strategy was not limited only
to
the stories we wanted also to create
an environment different new
environments to listen to podcasts
so
the first one and the one that i think
i'm very proud of is listening clubs we
we
got this tweet in 2017 november 2017. i
arrived in tribulating august 2017 so a
little less than two months before
for like two months before this vodka
before this tweet and this is diane
bellis a listener i didn't know her she
says
more than a podcast in our home it's
family it's what velux mixtape and i
discuss on wednesdays it's what my
parents listened to while bengali
which means come and help us to cut the
potatoes and she has in parenthesis
check out tablet next to cutting board
so there
they
start cutting potatoes together
uh and they're listening to an episode
and we were like oh my god people are
people are listening to this
together this is not like one of the
assumptions that we had for five years
ago is that podcasts are a very
intimate
individualistic
medium like you listen to your podcast
in your headphones and that's something
that it's sticking to your ear and to
your ear only and
they started challenging that assumption
and we got we started getting more and
more of these messages like then we were
seeing uh
some
colleagues at work in lunchtime
listening to an episode and we were like
okay this is something that is happening
that's interesting
and then we were like
oh my we need to tap into this
opportunity because maybe podcasts are
not necessarily
something that you should listen to
alone so we created listening clubs and
i want you to watch this three minute
video
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
so what happened when we opened this
this is the video that we published at
the beginning we had tested the idea we
did it you know in the cities where
team members were and we moderated those
conversations and we
like kind of calibrated the model
and then we opened it up and we ask
listeners you do it like now this is for
you we will not
we will not be organized listening clubs
it's not part of our
we don't have the capacity to do this
like we did this for you to do it so if
you want to use it here's everything and
we published and we gave them everything
as as i said in the video
and it was incredible and there have
been more than 20 250 listening clubs
organized by listeners in more than 50
cities around the world
this is a decentralized model this is a
model that
each of those listening clubs have be
have been
organized all the resources come from
listeners and it's something that people
feel
responsible for
accountable to each other and our
friendships and and things have started
because of this so more than 3 000
people across the world have gathered to
listen episodes together
this is the
this is one of the
screenshots of a map of 75 listening
clubs that happen on a day when we watch
our ninth season like listeners all over
the world organized the same clubs to
listen to the first episode of that
season the incentive was we're going to
give you the episode we're going to send
you the episode before it's published
for the world if you
connect with others in your community
and listen this together
we created a website and you can still
access it listeningpops.com
in which you can
connect with other listeners
which was the hardest thing because yes
yes i i am
in cambridge right now and i want to
listen to an episode with other people
but how do i know
where are they
so listeners were able in this website
to
put the event like and say hey i want to
host this and other listeners could see
oh there's someone in canvas who wants
to do this and they sign up
so it was easier to connect
and we started getting this kind of
picture so this is a this is a listening
club in panama strangers who connected
through latte and became friends this is
the same in mexico city
uh
some people started like expressing
their fomo and this is like someone like
hey does someone adopt me in a club i'm
from puerto rico and i can join online
when the pandemic started
uh
this is uh i i hit a neighborhood
because when the pandemic started some
clubs kept going to cafes
if it was safe to do it but other people
join online
and this is a picture of the new york
listening club which has met non-stop or
at least until 2021 met non-stop
since 2019 every week while we were in
season
we also
have done live shows in which
listeners go to uh to
these places in which we tell life
stories
and it is a way of
connecting us directly with the audience
and to
remember that what connects us as a
community is storytelling and listening
and what they what best way to do it and
telling stories live so we did we have
done tours uh of of that and also
another innovation or or engagement
strategy where these student parties in
which we invited people to celebrate in
a in a hard moment in our lives and to
remind ourselves that this is a
community this this is not a
a
group of individuals a network of
individuals but a community so we hired
dj's best djs
of latin american music and this is what
happened like people had fun people
once again
expressed that
or
yes indicated that
prime milante is not
an organization for them
it's not
an institution that's
that there's a distance between them
and this is a proof of that
so this is just like some gifts of of
how these parties went which is super
fun
it's so diverse i remember in like
i remember the first listening club that
i organized i almost cried of the
emotion i yes like
because it was incredible to see people
together strangers together being so
vulnerable and i remember
when i did this first party it was like
oh my god i just can't believe how much
trust these people have on us
and how privileged we are to
have connected this community
so a lot of tweets of celebration of the
listening clubs
they saying that is the biggest family
and joyful family in latin america where
the host
danielle says as usual that i wanted
to party and soon is life affirming
yes
a lot of of tweets just
celebrating and
somehow
affirming
our culture and the things that make us
together the last thing that i wanted to
show as innovation is lupa we know that
20 around 20 percent of flying blood to
listeners are
non-spanish speakers who are learning
spanish
so we
partner with a technology company and we
created this lupa lupa is an app that
uses dragon blanket stories to learn
spanish so spanish learners can at the
same time discover latin america through
documentaries audio documentaries and
learn spanish at the same time
so
all of those things that i have just
mentioned to you
led to something that
it's not the goal like we we we didn't
do it because of that but at the same
time
it's it's a it's a natural consequence
and it's also
necessary for these efforts to keep
going and that is the ambulance the
ambulance is the membership program for
flying
so listeners can become members and can
start donating in a regular basis to
and
in exchange they get some perks so they
get the episodes before their publishers
they get some stickers they get some
stuff yeah but basically it's not about
what they get back
but they contribute to the community
so we started inviting people we created
like this campaign to
make people join
this
and before
we created this in 2019
this was the budget of reimbursement so
60 of the
budget came out of foundations grants
36
out of npr which distributes the podcast
it has a
explosive distribution agreement and it
gives some money
in exchange of that agreement and four
percent of donations of listeners uh one
year after that
year and a half after that
this is how it changes so members were
giving 20 of the budget a 50.
that's a huge thing like that's a huge
revenue stream for an organization a
non-profit organization
because it means that
those who the organization are serving
are
feel responsible for the success of the
organization they are members they are
they're they're invested in in the
success of dragon ball
so storytelling at the end can lead like
good storytelling and
like honest authentic engagement can
lead to you being able to keep doing
what you love to do to keep working on
your mission
in which like
that is what's happening
so
that's what i wanted to show you of
concrete examples now i will
just go through
10 basic steps to build an engaged
community like
what did i learn what did we learn as an
engagement team
after doing
those things that you just saw right
so
let me just take 30 seconds of silence
because i know i've been talking a lot
so let's just 30 seconds of
just letting it in
and i'll start okay
okay
before
thinking about
doing
an engagement strategy for anything you
do like
you have a podcast you have a
newsletter you have
a storytelling project a hibernated
storytelling project you have a game
whatever you have
if you want to open it up and you want
to invite people to participate you need
to ask yourself these questions first
first is why do you want to do it what's
the motivation what are you expecting
out of it
do you want to do
engagement because you want them to
become members at the end or because you
want to expand the stories with the
knowledge that it's in the community
because you want to
have to trigger conversations that are
not happening you need to understand
what is your motivation
and also if you have the capacity to
maintain it over time because what
happens what usually happens is that
companies start companies or
organizations start investing in
engagement and
they
start doing this kind of prompts online
and
asking people to participate but then
they're overwhelmed but they're busy
with other stuff and then and they don't
have resources or attention to their
engagement efforts and people feel that
they're used that they're exploited that
their attention is just a resource that
the organization or the individuals are
mistreating so do you have the capacity
to maintain it over time to keep
listening to keep being to keep devoting
attention to those who are speaking to
you
how will you measure success is another
important
question and it's related to the first
one like will you read it will you
measure success because you have more
comments in your social media more likes
more shares more listeners or you will
measure success because the
conversations are super meaningful or
because
you've got to
mobilize 10 people 10 strangers to
gather in a cafe and get to know each
other like how will you measure success
that's important and it varies a lot it
depends on
what's your focus
are you willing to listen actively which
is which is like the
that question right because
as i said
you know like we know each of us know
when we are being listened
and
i as an engagement editor i'm on social
media
as a human being like i go to social
media and it's very easy for me to see
when a company or even a person an
influence or whatever is
asking questions
just because they
want to show or perform that they are
popular and that they're relevant in
their communities not because they
really care
about what they're asking
or and you know that because of the the
way they engage
with those who respond right
and also the last one is
what communities are meaningful to you
and this is a question that i
ask myself all the time
as a citizen as
me like
what are those communities are
meaningful to me and why like why is it
so important to me to participate in
this
a
conversation around x or y like why why
why do i feel so invested in this for
that community why i'm so why am i so
like
why do i feel so engaged in
conversations around
this or that topic
because those communities that are
meaningful to you will give you will be
your referent to the communities that
you want to create right that you want
to that you want to connect at the end
you don't create a community but you're
connected
so
the first principle is to define your
mission it's like that's
for like
state
one it's like how
what's your value and how do you
articulate that value in a narrative
that connects with people
and i
i usually think about missions as as as
a narrative like there is an art there
must be a conflict right what's the main
problem that you're tackling
and
after asking that
why you
should why are you invested there why
are you interested in that why what
why are you prepared to live in this in
this scenario this environment
and what's your plan what makes your
approach effective and unique and who
are you your allies
so in triamine's mission for example is
to bring greater understanding about
latin america using
audio storytelling that's it
right
and
that's that bring greater understanding
about latin america and latin in latinos
in the u.s
it's something that it's easy to connect
with because latinos
we have latinas we have been
so
affected by stereotypes in
outside latin america and even inside
latin america that to bring greater
understanding means that we're
challenging those stereotypes and the
way to challenge those stereotypes is
telling stories that show complex
characters that live ordinary lives but
they're complex right so that
complexity which is in every story of
rayon lente
is
kind of a symbol of what many latinos
and latinas feel that we just need to we
want to be to be seen as
three-dimensional human beings and
that's not usually happening in in some
environments so when you see someone who
has admission and has
skills and
a good plan like
those it's easier for for listeners to
connect to that and to see ray blante
more
not only like a one more podcast in your
list but someone who's helping you to
advance that goal that it's the goal of
that organization to
embrace our network mindset we are
online all the time right we're digital
beings now
so
what are the communities that are
already engaged in conversations around
the issues you cover you need to you
need to diagnose who are those people
who are already interested in those
issues and
how does the network structure looks
like how are they connected uh how many
people how how they behave
uh like how the information flows in
those in those networks
and then you need to engage with those
efforts it's not about this is me i hold
all the truth i know everything listen
to me but be humble and say hey
let's just
let's just
collaborate like what are you doing this
is what i'm planning to do how can we
work together
and
adapt like and this is
mostly in the journalism landscape but
like
journalism is now a finished product
it's not like uh it's not something that
it's already done when you publish it
but it's it's a process and i think that
to understand yourself as part of a
process and not as a product
a
yeah not as a production
company
it helps a lot to engage with people
so this is the
mindset of the of the productivity
factory and
in which things are just
unidirectional and in networks it's like
something that it's going on and it's
flowing in many directions and it's
connecting you with many anymore it's
not one too many but many too many
a go to know get to know those who share
your purpose so now that you have
diagnosed where those who are already
interested in what you're doing like get
to know them like who are they who are
your listeners listen to them what are
their questions what are they needs
maybe a lot of you here know about
design thinking or human-centered design
and it's just that it's like
who is the person who's listening to you
why do they find you valuable what other
stuff they need and maybe can you serve
them so this is why we ended up doing
lupa for example that that app for
spanish learners we knew that they were
listening to ryan blanton because they
wanted to learn spanish so we made it
easier
and at the same time we made it
profitable
collaborate let them know to welcome
their helping hands like that's why we
ask people you have great ideas we we we
cannot come up with new ideas every week
alone so let us know what kind of
stories would you like us to tell and
like just inviting them and knowing and
making making them know that you're open
to that makes a huge difference
and finally get data use service we did
a survey every year
we call people we did in person meetings
with people understand yes like
how can we
serve you better
share your expertise and this is what i
was saying about being reciprocal online
like
give give give like
this is
to me the spirit of the internet is
share share share because and this is
super heavy i'm sorry but then i think
when you're sharing a network it comes
back somehow right if you're actually
part of a network so
like
for three years we were giving giving
giving to the community we were not
asking for money only in specific
locations like giving tuesday like
specific days but we were mostly giving
and
when we felt ready to
install the membership program
immediately it started coming in and i
am aware i'm aware that
it's very hard to give three years a
if you're not getting back if you don't
have other revenue streams we had the
privilege of having the grants and
dr you get the concept like it's
you're in a network you have give and
you receive you give and you receive
respect people's attention because
there's a lot of noise out there and i
think this is
you know this is a huge
problem of the internet right now we're
saturated saturated with information our
attention span is limited so let's do
things that
stand out and that are valuable to
people and that feel useful and
meaningful and not
that's just not to make more noise
and recognize your blind spots like your
blind spot because
many times
we
are
so narrow-minded with the way we see the
world that we forget that there are many
things that we just don't know that we
don't do right and we should be humble
and ask like hey how can i get better
so
this is ways in which we share our
expertise we did a lot of workshops
like in which we
taught others how to
do a good interview for radio or in
which we
in in our website we created escuelara
which is free resources for those who
want to produce stories or we create a
newsletter in which we we were
recommending every week things that were
inspiring us online so other podcasts
music videos stories so we were all the
time just sharing sharing sharing
this one to me is super important and
it's related to the first part of the of
this talk in which
you should develop rituals and routines
because
it
i think networks and this is
a
quote from
caldarelli networks tried to explain how
a set of isolated elements are
transformed through a pattern of
interactions into groups and communities
and
what are those interactions what's the
pattern of interactions that you can
facilitate so a group is created right
you have a network
maybe some people are interested in what
you're interested but that doesn't mean
that there is a group and the community
is formed when those interactions become
regular become constant and they
they they have a pattern right so gather
meaningfully
be constant and make it unpredictable
and sometimes we feel that
yes to
talk to people or to get together let's
do uh
ask me anything or just let's do a
twitter space and then you just get
stuck in those kind of
uh platforms and there's much there are
many more ways to get together and if
you're not creative people will just
start seeing it as noise and repetitive
so
you need to create refreshing ways of
gathering meaningfully there's a great
book that it's called the art gathering
that i recommend if you're
planning to learn more about this
so this is an example we publish a story
about a girl who was kidna hypnotic in
latin america and then
we just asked people but the story was
about the family album of of
the family who
were
trying to find her here in the story and
then people started sending pictures of
their own
family albums which was great so it was
a way to connect people around the issue
of that episode a listening club is
another way
this is a virtual listening club just
like just expand the repertoire of
rituals that you
do to connect people
set rules to preserve trust which is
essential if people don't trust those in
the group they won't participate so you
need to create a cut of conduct and
moderate it we did that for the
listening clubs we did that for every
space online that we had
via connector it's not
only that you connect with your
listeners but you connect listeners
among each other
and see your community as a team
so these are pictures of the listening
clubs these are
like these are not strangers to us to to
us these listeners
are part of
and we we
see their collective
expertise and knowledge as
our knowledge
choose the right platform and this is
key
try to own your channels because if you
devote all your engagement work to
instagram twitter to facebook once they
change the rules then you're screwed so
you need to own your channel so have a
mailing list for example or list of
phone numbers that helps a lot make it
horizontal like how can you connect with
people not in a hierarchical way but
more like
at the same level and explore sometimes
it's great to do it online but sometimes
it's great just to do it offline
in dragon ball and this case we had
our own channel so this is the podcast
feed we publish our episodes and people
like this is something that we own it's
an
rss that we own or
whatsapp and whatsapp we had a huge list
of like three thousand almost four
thousand listeners and when whatsapp
didn't allow us to
create like broadcast lists we took all
those numbers and those numbers phone
numbers are hours it's not they're not
of whatsapp so that gave us a an ability
to react against a change of rules but
we still use the app in which we
last year we still we're using the app
in which in ways that were useful
and this is a newsletter which is an
also a
a list that you use so as a media that
you use that you own sorry
and finally make it look unique like
the visuals and the style they say a lot
about who you are even before people
start reading you or listening to you so
these are illustrations for different
episodes of
that are made by artists in this in the
region and these are original original
artwork that stands out in social media
we had a design team
yes that made it look
unique
and that is super important if you
really want to stand out and finally
enjoy
because i think that
social
like the engagement thing is about
getting together in
creative ways and joy is a big part of
it if it's boring unfortunately
there are many boring instances in
people's lives so you just have to make
it fun
and some useful frameworks this is a
this is at the membership guide of
a
the membership puzzle project which was
a project a of new york university and
they studied how people become
become members like if
how
an individual that is just becoming
aware of
a brand then becomes a really huge
engaged ambassador of the brand so that
that is a useful framework that you
could
study
this is a book called get together which
is also like a guidebook to understand
different communities and how can you
create or replicate that that things
that they that they found out there
and also this one it's super
to me was very
orienting it's called the community
campus which
divides the community building process
into three sections
that are
divided in themes that are very very
useful too
so that's it
from me hey
thank you so much for listening and i
would be happy to to answer questions
and yeah and just to talk thank you
i will stop sharing
thank you um jorge
um we're all muted so i think other
people are applauding but maybe you can
only hear me
um so yeah let's open up two uh
questions we have um 20 minutes or so
for discussion who would like to kick us
off
um i think tomas had his hand up there
first
uh thank you for a fantastic talk and
i i was especially interested in the
fact that you mentioned uh your revenue
strategies and how you monetized uh how
you made the party sustainable which i
think is super interesting and i was
wondering and i understand this is kind
of the most pressing problem for
independent media
and i was wondering if you could share
some advice you would give to to other
similar products uh or interested in
monetizing their platform their their
medium and make them make it sustainable
yes yes i think that
it did at the like the bottom line to me
but you know like to someone with a
hammer everything is a nail and to me
that i'm thinking about communities to
me the bottom line is to have a
community that
actually it's actually invested in what
you do so for example i am part of uh
a community in colombia that is led by
this woman who's publishing content
about how can we be more friendly and
loving with the earth right how can we
be more conscious of what we're doing to
the earth and she has been publishing in
a blog for like 10 years and like two
years ago she was like hey
if i if i if i i want to keep doing this
but i cannot do it
without your support so
she created this patreon and
hundreds maybe thousands of people are
part of that community and allow her to
do that but
they they are
they are so engaged
because she has been
constant
she has been generous she's
clever she's insightful she's what she
publishes useful it has changed our
lives it makes us feel part of uh
of something that is larger than
ourselves it's it
it connects like she is a reference of
the change that we want to make and
when you become that when you're in the
if you're in independent media if your
mission is very clear and what you're
doing it's really useful and you are
effective inviting people to
follow your work to make it better if
you're listening to them and asking them
hey what you need and how can i help you
when you get to that point in which the
community is large enough and
it's event it will eventually happen
then you can say okay like this is what
we have we're here together we're part
of this you are connected to each other
because we are doing this work but if we
want to keep doing this together we need
we need your support and your financial
support and it's completely okay to say
that openly and people respond in ways
that surprise you like positive ways
that surprise you so
my advice is is that is like give
be useful listen back
uh
serve to the needs of the people and
make your purpose super clear so people
feel that you are advancing a mission
that is your mission and it's their
mission too
either is it right for if i do a small
follow-up question
yeah
all right so
thank you thank you for that that seems
really interesting and it's true that
once a community gets a certain size
then it is there you can find a slice
that is willing to fund you right but i
wonder if
if if how do you like if you've been
giving your community free content for a
while why would they expect to to pay
you which is what i see a lot of content
creators
grapple with right like how
do you communicate to them that your
work needs to be funded in a in a
situation where so much content is
available for free right
so i recommend you to check
and study if this is something that you
are you're trying to do go and with the
membership guide
and it's part of the membership puzzle
project it was their final project so
the membership puzzle project is still
there but
a in a in a new way but there's
something called the membership guide
that they produced last year
and they
dissected
a lot of organizations that have
been in that exact situation like how we
how do we do how we create membership
like how can we make people
support us and they have a lot of cases
which are super super interesting but i
just want to highlight something that
they say and one of the reasons why
people
become members
is not because of the content but
because of the community because if you
if you connect a community
and
like then people
will feel that
if you're not there the community will
not be there and they don't want that
loss they don't want to lose that
community because the community is what
is giving a lot of value to their lives
so
somehow
if creating the community is at the same
time creating the base for your
sustainability because the community is
what people value and they will pay
to be part of that community
great thank you
so yes and that's the membership yes
that's membership guide andrew that you
put in the chat thank you oh good yeah i
saw that question thank you andrew um
next we have amber
thank you heather uh thank you jorge for
this amazing talk i was especially
interested in
when you were talking about like making
the story growth and storytelling as an
open-ended process
but i and i was wondering how did you
choose which specific like episodes or
themes to use for your community
engagement in social media because i'm
assuming that not all
episodes
were you know like you continue
using it so yeah yeah definitely there
are some episodes like political
episodes that are just like no there's
not there's not
no human
it's harder to identify with so the
episodes that that we use for this kind
of exercises were those episodes in
which
you as
in which the universal experience of the
character was easier to see
was i was easy to identify so migration
for example
or
your connection to a city
in
your
your relationship with your with with an
object like appreciate software in your
family things that you're like oh yes i
get this i get this i get
like i can translate that into my life
super easily but those episodes that
were more
focused on
hyper-specific things of the reality of
latin america
they were harder to to translate it to
this kind of engagement but yes like
it's human experience and universal like
universal
universal experience
thank you
thank you um
i was wondering if you could
you talked about so many successful
engagement strategies
um
well first i want to say i'm super
impressed by your
optimism about the internet there's a
moment where you actually said the
internet is for listening and i was like
that's great because of course we've all
had sort of the opposite experience and
especially with twitter right and and
things can can go awry
um
and um you know i was wondering if you
could talk about some of your engagement
strategies that maybe failed or were
less strong and you know what you
learned from that uh for for going
forward
oh yes many of them many many many many
like many of engagement prompts had
several responses five responses
and
i think that
thing that
we learned
after many failures is that
you cannot ask
people
to
think a lot like to reflect a lot
before
starting typing and starting thinking
about their interaction or their
intervention so
many questions felt like paper questions
and people won't
like stop their
social media feed to
write down homework they just don't want
that they just want to have fun or they
just want to
go to a place in their mind which is not
the place in their mind that they have
to go to
write down a thesis right so it needs to
be closer to their heart it needs to be
a it needs to be in that sweet spot of
emotionally
emotions and
argument
uh and that is very hard to craft into a
prompt so many of the crowns were felt
like very mental very rational and
people just ignored that completely so
in many of the stories in some of the
stories we asked people to
give opinions
that
they were not interested in thinking
about the complexity of the situation in
their own lives
and because start very because the
prompt is difficult
very few responses happen and because
very few responses happen less people
see it and at the end it's just for it
in in the feed
so that's something right that we
learned about about how to craft prompts
uh
and how can be how can you be creative
and meaningful at the same time
at the beginning of the pandemic we did
an exercise that where there was
relatively frivolous superf like
it was
yes it was stupid
it could be seen as stupid but it worked
and it was like we started asking people
when we were locked down all around the
world
we wanted to
understand how are they perceiving the
world
so we focus on a sense every week a
different sense every week so we started
asking people
show us what you're saying
uh
send us a picture of what you're seeing
in the first window at your right hand
and then hundreds of things then
send us uh
i don't remember which center like all
of the senses but every sense had a
different prompt and it worked and what
it what what happened what what we were
trying to do is to understand
the community as a body as a single body
with thousands of eyes each listener was
an eye each listener was a like a nose a
flavor what what what did you what was
the last thing that you read in this
pandemic or before the pandemic started
something like that so we were
thinking about the community as a
huge system as a huge body
and
i say this this was a successful case
but i say this because what you want
is to
go to the senses go to the sensual
before
before of the mind of course some topics
are good to think about and to like be
rational and to have some conversations
it's very hard to have that
but when you go to
what you're feeling and when you touch
that in people people
immediately start participating so the
sweet spot between the sensual and the
rational it's something that we learned
after many failures
thank you um
do we have any other questions
i mean i have one more
oh andrew yes
yeah thank you so much jorge this has
been wonderful um
you really got me thinking about
uh reminding me of an experience that i
had
when you talked about the listening
groups
um
so this was
several years ago i taught a podcasting
class and one of the things i was
worried about
was
the selections that i had for for
listenings were students going to engage
with them so
during
mit's january
sort of period where you can teach
whatever class that you want i invited
people to come listen to the things i
was going to use in the semester long
class and that was the first time i'd
been in a room
with people sitting around a table and a
speaker in the center
all listening to the same thing at the
same time
um
and i realized that
gosh like 99 of the time that we're
consuming media
whether it's
in a movie theater at a concert hall
uh televisions in our own house
everything we're we're sitting staring
at the same thing in the same direction
um as opposed to those rooms
where you're listening to something and
you're sitting around you're watching
each other react to the same things and
sort of getting a read of each other's
faces
i guess my question was you guys also
did that over zoom is that right
yes can you do people have the same
experience doing those groups over zoom
like media through a computer screen as
they did when they were listening in
person together
i think i think yes
but it's harder and of course there are
many things that you cannot
read
in a like in a screen because
when you're when you're
in a room in a round table as you say
watching each other you can feel the
energy you can you can feel the
attention of the room you can feel
the tension you can feel
the
what's flowing right you become like a
single entity and and when someone is
anxious when someone is
feeling nervous because speaking up
about something that it's hard to
process there are many things that you
you read
in the body
in soon it's easier
i think just to
be a little bit distant
but overall the quality of the
conversation i think was was
very good in soon so it was less
emotional it was less emotional but it
was good like it was it was insightful
it was diverse
it gave no ideas
like one of the things that sometimes we
we did listening clubs for stories
before publishing them to see if there
were things that were not clear that
were not
that were that could be improved and
that
was great in person or
in some like that worked either way but
i think that
when you get in a room with strangers
when it's like in soon the listening
clubs were 100 300 people
instead
in in a in a in a room we were 12 people
15 people so there's kind of like there
is more vulnerability there right
there's more
it's more fragile and and that's
something that you cannot replicate very
digitally
i think we will um we've got one last
question i want to take from the
attendees who aren't in the uh
the panelist
side of it um this is from um aguinaldo
melo who asks how do you see podcasts
serving as a medium to enable
storytelling and how do you think we can
promote a similar kind of storytelling
on other mediums this is a question of
the medium or the message
that's the question
i think the podcast has ha they they
have its own thing
uh it's very like we can go here into
what makes podcasts different from radio
i think that
it's mostly the same but there's a huge
difference which is that you know who's
listening to you
and because you know who's listening to
you there's
there's a reciprocal relationship and
there there is a connection that you
cannot have on radio of course on radio
there were you you knew that where there
were like groups of people listening to
you you could know where you're
a
average listener or they could send you
things letters whatever but in in
podcasts there's this
because we're it's a digital medium you
have data on who's listening to you
where
uh when the attention is dropping
you know you you have many data points
that inform you about who's on the other
side and at the same time like they can
just
write you they can they leave your
reviews they send you emails
so
that ability to know who's on the other
side
gives you if you're if you're paying
attention
or shapes if you're paying attention the
way you talk to that person right so
i think that podcast
good
podcast feel so close
to you
because they know who you are because
they're seeing you right
almost in real time not in real time but
it's
data is so fresh that they know who's
there and they know how to talk to you
and you feel that the podcasts you love
are talking to you not to people similar
to you but to you
and and i cannot emphasize that enough
so i think that this is about the medium
of course that enables the storytelling
feel so close
but i think that
i think it's possible to replicate that
or that that would be translated to
other
medium digital mediums right but i i
i don't know
if that's the case in the other mediums
so
if as a journalist that has experimented
in magazines in
video documentaries in radio
and podcast i like the one in which i
see higher engagement much higher
engagement is in podcasts
that is really interesting i'm really
glad that um
we got into some issues about medium
specificity at the end there that's
great i think that wade roush who's in
our um attendee pool might uh summarize
things the best for us to close out he
said um
fantastic sessions so inspirational for
those of us working to build community
and podcasting congrats jorge and enjoy
the rest of your year at harvard i would
echo that thank you so much
and i'm just going to say one more thing
just put in a little plug for next
week's uh colloquium series we have
hillary chute speaking uh from
northeastern and she's going to be
talking about mouse and um i'll just add
that you know
he arranged this um maybe almost two
months ago um she said her project was
about the you know continuing relevance
of mouse and she was sort of asking like
you still feel like it's relevant and i
was like oh absolutely and of course
this was before the recent uh crisis and
and controversy around mouse in in
tennessee so it's a good it's going to
be a terrific terrific talk so
um i will see all the grad students
there and i hope to see many of our
other attendees there as well
um thank you again jorge and um good
night to everyone
thank you so much
bye